يكشف عن مشكله صحيه بسبب ظروف الحرب مشهد
حزين من نهر دجله في العراق انقطاع
الكهرباء عن عشرات الالاف في كاليفورنيا
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بعد عام على الحرب الطاحنه التي تشهدها
بلاده كشف رئيس الاوكراني فولوير زيلينسكي
عن حاله صحيه استجدت عليه ولم يكن يعاني
منها سابقا قال ان بصره تراجع بشكل كبير
حتى انه لم يعد قادرا على قراءه ما هو
مكتوب على ملصق كيس الشاي واصبح يلجا الى
النظاره للقراءه عازيا ذلك لكثره العمل في
مكتبه في ظل اناره سيئه حيث تستدعي ظروف
الامنيه ذلك
انعكاس لنقص الشديد في المياه وسياسات
التقنين المتبعه اظهرت مشاهد صادمه في
العراق تعرض نهر دجله لحاله جفاف غير
مسبوقه لدرجه ان بعض المواطنين عبروه سيرا
على الاقدام وزاره الموارد المائيه
العراقيه حذرت من ان المخزون المائيه في
البلاد بات على المحك مشيره الى ان العراق
فقد سبعين بالمئه من حصصه المائيه بسبب ما
وصفتها بسياسه دول الجوار بحسب ما ذكرته
وكاله الانباء العراقي
نحو 85 الف منزل وشركه في منطقه لوس
انجلوس في الولايات المتحده انقطعت عنها
الكهرباء مع استمرار العواصف في ضرب اجزاء
من ولايه كاليفورنيا ما ادى الى تساقط
الثلوج وهطول الامطار اداره النقل في
كاليفورنيا قالت ان الطريقه السريعه خمسه
وهو اكبر طريق سريع يؤدي الى الشمال خارج
المدينه ظل مغلقا بسبب ثلوج الكثيفه بينما
تم اغلاق العديد من النقاط الجنوبيه
الاخرى من الطريق السريع في لوس انجلوس
ومحيطها بسبب الفيضانات
احصائيات صادمه اوردتها دراسه بحثيه كشفت
ان حكام الدوري الايطالي لكره القدم
يشهرون البطاقات الصفراء والحمراء للاعبين
ذوي البشره السمراء اكثر من زملائهم ذوي
البشره الفاتحه بحسب ما نقلت صحيفه
البريطانيه الدراسه قالت ان الحكام في
الدوري الايطالي الاول احتسبوا اخطاء على
اللاعبين ذوي البشر السمراء بزياده بلغت
عشرين في المئه كل موسم خلال المده من عام
2009 الى 2019 مع زياده بنسبه 11% في عدد
البطاقات الصفراء وبنسبه 16% في عدد
البطاقات الحمراء لكنها اشارت الى ان هذا
التحيز اختفى في فتره كورونا عندما كانت
المباريات تقام بدون جمهور
في اول رد رسميا مصريه على بيع جواز سفر
الرئيس الراحل انور السادات في مزاد علني
بامريكا اعلنت مكتبه الاسكندريه انها لم
تتسلم جواز السفر من العائله ضمن مقتنيات
الرئيس الراحل ردوا مكتبه الاسكندريه جاء
بعد ان فاجئت صاله مزادات امريكيه روادها
بعرض جواز السفر الدبلوماسي للرئيس المصري
الراحل للبيع في مزاد علني فيما قالت
المكتبه ان جميع المقتنيات المتعلقه
بالسادات لديها محفوظه بالمكتبه حفظا
مخزانيا ومتحفيا تحت قواعد حفظ وضبط بيئي
صارمه